we're going to have a or I guess the
National Organization of Women and and
the UN women's Society or whatever have
planned a I think it's from the 7th to
the 9th of October there's going to be
this big worldwide March for women's
rights and women's issues and abortion
and this and everything else all things
women so uh really what it is it's sort
of what I call tilling the fields
they're they're seeding sort of this
sentiment so that when they get to that
point prior to the November elections uh
it'll be like okay ladies make sure you
get out there and vote because if you
don't go out there and vote then uh you
know uh abortion is going to be what it
is you know and uh women women are
losing rights left and right and so
therefore if you don't get out there uh
it's going to be a failure on the part
of women because women are the ones who
who basically decide elections really
since I would say since the well if you
could say 1920s but but uh certainly
since this since the post-sexual
revolution generation yeah let's be
clear about what that is when you talk
about the National Organization for
Women you talk about these women's
marches these are pro-abortion movements
at large these are these are not these
are not movements that care about women
or you wouldn't have seen the heads of
the National Organization for Women
shaking hands with the likes of Bill
Clinton who was a total womanizer it's
not about that it's all about politics
it's all agenda driven it's you know the
left-wing agenda at its best and now
somehow you know they'll talk about
equal pay which we've dissected on this
show which we know that that's a huge
myth the way that it's presented by the
left they'll talk about you know women's
rights being confined to their ability
to murder a baby in late stages and
that's where it ends really you know
they don't really talk about issues that
really stand to benefit women and and
they and it's a it's a pro hyper
promiscuity culture that they're seeking
to you know embellish and and add to so
that let's be clear about what that is
and I think you're right I think they're
gearing up right now for a midterm
election season that they need to rely
heavily on the recent abortion ruling
which has been distorted they have tried
to make it you know sound like abortion
has been removed that it's now illegal
when instead what really happened is
this became a state's rights issue which
is where it should have stood all along
so I think you're 100 right the
manipulation that's going on right now
with respect to women you're going to
see by the way roller you're going to
see just quickly women's magazines
picking up on all of that I mean this is
just gonna become a thing yeah go ahead
please well it started um I was gonna
say uh it was Elizabeth
um Elizabeth Elizabeth Warren was uh it
started really I think it was late March
or early April when she started talking
about how they really needed to lean on
President Biden for uh was it a student
debt consolidation or two student debt
forgiveness and when you look statistic
I've had these discussions by the way
with George Gammon on valuetainment of
all places too uh we were talking about
how the student debt forgiveness was
actually part of the Biden platform you
know back in 2020 and he never really
made good on it well the reason for that
is because they were reserving that for
the for the midterm elections and so
you've got Elizabeth Warren who is I I
still have the tweet I could probably go
dig it up for you
um but she was saying you know we really
need to lean on President Biden this is
March of this year we need to lean on
him for uh to make good on his campaign
Promises of debt for debt forgiveness
because it gives women a fair shake or a
women a fair start and the reason why
she's bringing that up is because
two-thirds of the of uh at least
two-thirds of student debt in the United
States is held by women because women
enroll and graduate at much higher rates
than men do so it is what At Last I
counted it was I believe at 1.7 trillion
dollars was the debt and uh so that was
a big deal and I I jumped all over that
because I knew that that was coming
um and so that happened right before
like literally like two weeks before the
quote-unquote uh scotus the Supreme
Court of the United States uh leak about
how they were going to rule on Roe v
Wade and it was a leak and everybody was
losing their minds but they knew it was
coming I mean if you go and you listen
to the rhetoric of that time you listen
to Kamala Harris you listen to Elizabeth
Warren you listen to like uh AOC during
that time during April to about May when
the league hit this was before the
ruling they were just losing their minds
because they knew that that was the plan
they knew that that was the narrative
that they were going to go with sure as
hell as soon as uh you know June rolls
around they can't like you said they
kick it back to the States it's not a
federal thing now it's back to the
States that's when you see uh companies
like Tesla and um and Morgan Stanley
Starbucks uh Amazon Are all uh coming up
with these these uh plans to say Ladies
If you happen to live in a non-abortion
state and there's another abortion State
that's next to you we're going to give
you up to four thousand dollars in a
passport so that you can cross state
lines go have an abortion in another
state and then bring and then come back
and go back to work for Amazon or first
Morgan Stanley or whoever's you know
offering the the thing for you you know
offering the stipend to you and as if
that's a benefit part of the benefits
package if you you happen to have a
vagina and you work for those companies
so the fact that they're already they
were already planning and preparing to
do that prior to the ruling even coming
down that lets you know what that the
narrative the fix is already in that the
narrative is already there so when I was
looking at that I'm like okay now we're
back to the gender War now we're back to
gender politics because that's how
they're going to get the ladies out to
the out to the polls in November and I I
made this prediction back in March I
said you're going to see it ramp up
right around the end of August maybe
into the middle of September and here we
are we're making villains of incels uh
We've also got the um the young lady
you're probably you're probably I'm
sorry if I'm preempting you here but
you're probably going to talk about the
young lady in
foreign
yeah I think we're probably we're going
to get to that but the um the uh the
idea that uh that women's issues are an
international crisis and not just an
American crisis it's going to ramp up
right up until we get to the point where
we're at uh the about November 8th and
then right around November 9th November
10th all that goes away yeah you know
what's interesting you were talking
about those companies that are going to
Great Lengths now when it comes to
abortion and female employees it's
interesting a lot of those companies
didn't step up to the plate when people
were forced to get an experimental
vaccine that their own doctors advise
against they weren't rushing to make
arrangements for those people to keep
their jobs fascinating to watch Politics
on display if you want to watch the full
episode you're going to click right here
and if you want to ask me a question one
on one you want to do a one-on-one face
time with a group of your friends
whatever you want you need to download
manect right now click right here and
let's get talking
foreign
[Music]